hey guys so we're gonna go to dinner now
see you soon beautiful my name is
Dolores but you would call me daddy
Khloe Kardashian is no stranger to a
funny accent or two I had a two
grandchildren can't remember their names
but it turns out khlomoney has been
giving us funny and somewhat confusing
accents three years
yep that's vintage home video footage of
khloe as a kid giving younger sisters
Kendall and Kylie Jenner a bath in the
kitchen sink
Kendall shared the vid to Instagram on
Monday and while it's adorable it's
Khloe's bizarre accent that has fans on
social media talking yes we've got on a
journey there from Khloe's accent being
southern to British but we're not the
only ones who got a kick out of it
the Kardashians themselves weighed in in
the comments including Courtney who
hilariously asked what kind of accent
does Khloe Kardashian have Khloe clapped
right back writing I was waiting for you
to chime in and hate on my beautiful
accent Kim also gushed over the video
so did Caitlyn Jenner fast forward a
decade or two and caring big sister
Khloe is now a proud mama herself et sat
down with her in October and she opened
up about life and staying focused on her
baby girl true I'm just super happy in
content and
Gaston work and like taking care of me
my body and soul and true and I just I'm
having so much fun with her
[Music]